so we've been waiting for it and it's
happening Donald Trump is now publicly
saying he believes that foreign
countries he won't say which ones will
be rigging the upcoming presidential
election against him
this is particularly funny to use a word
that really lightens the situation it's
really tragic but it's sort of funny for
Trump to predict that other countries
will rigged the election against him
since he has repeatedly said he would
consider accepting help from other
countries in according to John Bolton
even asked China for help but I'm
getting ahead of myself let's let's wait
for a moment because there's a few
stories here first is that in general
Donald Trump has appeared to be
particularly on tilt over the last few
weeks on tilt is a term from chess and
poker sometimes from other games where
when you take a bad beat you make a
mistake or you appear to get unlucky or
you make an error then it influences
your future behavior and you behave even
more erratically during future games and
moments and that seems to be got what's
going on with Donald Trump yet his
failed rally on Saturday in Tulsa
Oklahoma
slumping into the White House with a tan
stained white shirt out of his
helicopter on late Saturday night
reportedly yelling at his staff for the
lack of turnout we covered it all
yesterday
meanwhile he sees that polling is not
looking so good and now Donald Trump is
loudly and wildly proclaiming that
foreign countries are going to rig the
election against him and this is another
instance of Donald Trump maybe we don't
really know what he's doing and it may
not even be a you know a thought-out
strategy but he may be laying the
groundwork to contest the results of the
election in the future when he loses he
could argue he didn't really lose
because it was rigged and he's been
talking about it being rigged and
priming his followers to believe it will
be rigged for months Trump writing
yesterday on Twitter quote this is all
caps by the way I'm not going to do
anything in my reading to reflect that
it's all caps just know that it's all
caps rigged 2020 election millions of
mail-in ballots will be printed by
foreign countries and others
it will be the scandal of our times then
tweeting minutes later because of all
caps mail-in ballots 2020 will be the
most rigged capital e election in our
nation's history no apostrophe on
nation's unless this stupidity is ended
we voted during World War one and World
War two with no problem but now they are
using Co vyd in order to cheat by using
mail and that's the president by the way
that's not some conspiracy theorist
who's like a third string or Alex Jones
tweeting that that's the President of
the United States at least for a few
more months so remember he spent the
last three and a half years arguing that
an election he won was rigged against
him so of course he's going to say that
it was rigged if indeed he loses and
this is a particularly unhinged claim
foreign countries are going to print
ballots and what fill them in and send
them to local polling precincts like
what's funny about this is that Trump
knows so little about how voting works
that he seems to think this could be an
actual thing that could be done like
Trump has been on this unhinged crusade
against vote-by-mail for a couple of
months now saying it leads to fraud and
so on and so forth here he says the
fraud would be foreign countries would
print massive numbers of ballots all I
guess perfectly formatted to match the
format of any particular precinct fill
them in as votes for Biden and then send
them by mail
now absentee ballots as you may know are
only sent to registered voters like if
you send in a thousand ballots saying Oh
Joe Smith voted for Biden and Nancy
Smith voted for Biden and Joe Smith jr.
voted for Biden and Joe Smith the third
like when they're received they're
checked against a registered voter list
in that precinct if that person isn't
actually registered to vote in that
precinct then the ballot is thrown out
if the person already submitted a ballot
then another one coming in with their
same name is going to be thrown out and
not counted this would be an insanely
stupid way to try to steal an election
and then by the way
so layer one is Trump is until layer two
is this is a dumb way to steal an
election
number three is it's particularly
stunning that Trump is decrying foreign
interference because you might remember
that in an interview with George
Stephanopoulos he was actually asked you
know if Russia offered help dirt so to
speak if China offered it would you
accept it and Trump said that he might
let me remind you about that interview
from a few months back this is somebody
that said we have information on your
opponent oh let me call the FBI give me
a break
life doesn't work our director says
that's what should happen the FBI
director is wrong your campaign this
time around if foreigners if Russia if
China if someone else offers you
information on opponents should they
accept it or should they call the FBI I
think maybe you do both I think you
might want to listen I don't there's
nothing wrong with listening if somebody
called from a country Norway we have
information on your opponent oh I think
I'd want to hear you want that kind of
interference in our elections it's not
an interference they have information I
think I'd take it if I thought there was
something wrong I'd go maybe to the FBI
if I thought there was something wrong
but when somebody comes up with Apple
research right they come up with up or
research oh let's call the FBI the FBI
doesn't have enough agents to take care
of it but you go and talk honestly to
congressmen they all do it they always
have and that's the way it is
it's called Oppo research now the reason
Trump is doing this is very clear he's
seen the polls and he's scared you know
publicly he claims every poll is fake if
it says that he's losing even when it's
a Fox News poll even when it's a
Rasmussen poll but privately we've heard
reports that Trump is absolutely furious
with his staff he doesn't understand how
he's losing so badly Fox News had Biden
ahead by 12 last Thursday Quinnipiac had
Biden ahead by 8 CNBC has Biden +10
economist has Biden up 9 new poll out of
New Hampshire says Biden his plus 7 that
was tied almost in 2016
Paul says Biden plus 7 there's a Florida
poll that says Biden plus 7 I I find
that a little bit hard to believe but
then a tip poll has Biden plus 11 in
Florida
it's insane as the point and we all have
to vote but clearly Donald Trump is
triggered by the polling so now we'll
wait and see what happens in November
but the important thing to address here
is that if Donald Trump thinks foreign
countries are going to rig the election
against him why hasn't he done anything
about it
if it was rigged in 2016 against Trump
and he believes it'll be rigged in 2020
against him why is it that for the last
three and a half years despite numerous
attempts from mostly Democrats to
actually toughen up and harden our
election systems so they are not subject
to foreign interference why has Trump
opposed all of those measures why is
miss Mitch McConnell opposed all of
those measures and ideas that have been
put forward it's because any good story
needs an enemy and here the enemy is
so-called foreign votes mail and boats
double voting etc etc it's not real and
the final sort of insanity and hypocrisy
here is once again that this is
something that Trump allegedly went out
and solicited according to john bolton
it's not just what Trump said to George
Stephanopoulos well if they sent it to
me I'd look at it it's actually the
allegation is that Trump went to the
Chinese president and said listen I need
farmers to help get me reelected in
November of 2020 can you start buying
more stuff from our farmers to help me
get reelected it's not just he would be
willing to accept it it's he allegedly
went out and solicited it and that's
what makes this all so so insane now
let's talk about the next level of crazy
which is Donald Trump coming out against
the first amendment here in the United
States